frostrus resonance energy transfer or
Freight is a non-radiative energy
transfer process here the donor is
excited and the acceptor is basically
accepting the resonance energy and it
fluorescence
so it's a non-radiative energy transfer
process and this happens due to
non-radiative dipole dipole coupling
key applications of freight include
protein protein introduction study or
principle of freight can be used to
create molecular sensors so sales fret
is very much sensitive to distance
when the distance is high there is no
Freight
this is the Fret profile how it looks
like in case of freight you can see the
excitation and excitation and emission
spectrum also it's important to note
that Freight is sensitive to distance
and fret efficiency can be calculated
based on the distance
and in this case you can see the formula